[موسيقى]
كان الالعاب
اني احب بعض
على الحديقه نلعب
نطلع فوق نلعب
نروح على دار سيدي
نطلع انا وابوي واخوي
[موسيقى]
اجا مستعجل على الدنيا وطلع مستعجل انا
لما اعدم وابني قدام عيني مش سهله مش سهله
انا لما زوجي قدامي برشوا فيهم قدامي
انتهكت حرمتنا كلنا
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي هيثم التميمي والد الشهيد محمد
التميمي ابلغ من العمر 44 عام من قريه
النبي صالح شمال غرب رام الله
اسكن في منزل قريب من نقطه الاحتلال
النقطه العسكريه اللي هي برج الجيش
والبوابات العسكريه اللي بتدخل منطقه بني
زيد تعرضت لحادث
يعني
جريمه دخلت البيت الولد اصر انه يظل يلعب
بره فاضطريت اني انا اكون يعني قريب منه
العب معه بره استعدت انه معي لخروج زياره
عائليه في القريه يعني لابن عم قلنا دخلت
انا والطفل للسياره السياره تعرضت لاطلاق
نار مباشر من القوات الاحتلال
انا فتت اجهز حالي سمعت اطلاق نار
طلعت اركض باب البيت
اطلعت برشوا بالسياره اللي الزوجه هو فيها
وابني بدخلها ابني اتصاوب براسه
وزوجي
رصاصتين حيه بكتفه
وشظايا عندي الوريد اللي هون اللي في
الرقبه او انا اطلع عليهم وهم يرشوا فيكم
ومش قادر اوصل لهم
فلما
وقف اطلاق النار طلعت اركض عليهم يعني صار
زوج محرك السياره وطالع يا دوب 10 متر
بيني وبين
دار سيدو لزوجي
وحاولنا انه يعني نكمل رحلتنا للعلاج باب
المستوطن لانه هم قريبين علينا فانه
لكونه الجيش طبعا على البوابه وسحبوا
السلاح علينا وكانوا خايفين انه احنا
نتقدم خايفين انه احنا نوصلهم
كانوا يصرخوا علينا من بعيد ارجعوا كانوا
يصرفوا
السياره اطفوا الاناره رفع الطفل مقابل
وجه الجندي فشاف انه الطفل يعني
مباشره يعني اعطى للجيش انه يفتحوا الحاجز
لانه في اشي طارق انا قعدت بالمستشفى اربع
ايام او ثلاث ايام بالمناسبه
ما كنت شاعر صدقا عن الم ما كنت شاعر عن
جرحي ما كنت شاعر انه انا يعني كان البعد
سبب الم يعني بعدي عن ابني انه انا اطمئن
كنت اتواصل مع
زوجتي مع ام الطفل كانت هناك
اتواصل معها باللحظات يعني اصحى بالليل
ارن عليها اصحابي الانهار ارن عليها
[موسيقى]
انا جبته بالشهر الثامن كان خطر علي وعليه
يعني وجبته الحمد لله ومن فضل ربنا ربنا
كتب له انه يعيش
دكاتره حكولي معجزه انه عيش قاعد في
الحضانه شهر
والحمد لله اجى مستعجل على الدنيا وطلع
مستعجل وطفل عمره سنتين وخمس شهور رضيع
اعدموه قدام عينين امه قدام عينين امه
انا فقدت اخوي اللي بقيت العب معاه
الباكيت انا نحب بعض كنا نحضر مع بعض
يطلعني
[موسيقى]
العب في البلالين يمكن انه
نلعب في الفوتبول
[موسيقى]